okay let's go to our caller from the two
four zero area code caller from two four
zero what's your name where you come
from ma
yes I can okay so my name is Kyle
so I'm 14 and so I recently got into
politics when I first got in I kind of
got like you know the whole auntie SJW
subculture type thing right so like I
kind of got sucked into that whole thing
and I was kind of like a really huge fan
of like all those pseudo-intellectuals
for like a whole year so let me see if I
understand Kyle you weren't into
politics at all but what pulled you into
politics initially was the internet sort
of red pill anti SJW echo chamber yeah
initially that was and then like so when
I want when I started watching you at
some point it was you and a channel you
know secular talk well I watched you you
two guys you guys are the guys who kind
of like pulled me out of that so that's
pretty dope but you know it's a lot of
friends I got a lot of friends who are
still kind of like that you know they're
still watching those student elections
they still like echo chamber in those
you know kind of BS talking points you
know and are they also or are they also
like 14 years old
oh yeah pretty much you know that's I
think you'll in ten in ten or fifteen
years you'll understand Kyle that that
is extraordinarily depressing because
when people get sucked into an ideology
at that age you've done something
notable by getting yourself out of it
and I'm glad that I was able to play a
role in that because it can be really
difficult when someone's indoctrinated
into that type of stuff at your age to
get them out yeah yeah I get that um I
was wondering like do you have any
suggestions for Alec and I kind of
convinced them to otherwise convince
them is kind of like get out of that
like echo chamber you I mean listen I
think the best example is what got you
out right so it's it's presenting other
perspectives it's trying to avoid these
kind of tribalistic via
confrontations and just you know
exposing them to other ideas and using
what happened to you as a model but it
can be if people don't want to see
reason if people get into an ideology
without reasoning their way into it it
can be hard to reason them out of it and
that this is one of the biggest
challenge that is challenges that is out
there right now yeah definitely it's uh
kind of like an epidemic for like kids
my age a lot of kids are getting sucked
into that hole now let me ask you this
if I can what part of the country
generally do you live in a pretty solid
blue state okay Maryland and when you go
you go to public or private school I go
to a magnet school okay when you go in
is there I mean is are the kids abuzz
about like Jordan Peterson and whatnot
our 14 year old colleagues of yours
talking about did you see what Jordan
Peterson said yeah like Jordan Peterson
what a mad lad oh my god he wrecked
those live tarts are yours here that's
those are the conversations that are
happening in the marriage
Mike yes we're in trouble that's
depressing Kyle listen I congratulate
you on getting out of that echo chamber
they spread it spread spread the
antidote like a virus if you can that's
all that's my advice for you yeah thanks
and also thank you for pulling me out of
that so I appreciate it and Pat make
notes we've got to bleep a lot of calls
today okay Kyle thank you very much
great to hear from Kyle what can you say
it's it's bad out there folks it's
really really bad out there